I I have to say this too because I think
this is incredible and I don't know any
other artist that has accomplished this
but this is another number one for you
and you have number one spanning seven
decades
like no one will accomplish that two of
us have who are you going to say a band
don't say a band it's a band it doesn't
count took four of them to be one of me
y
that's my
favorite exactly Rolling Stones me
that's incredible right and I'm not in
the rocking H Hall of Fame
wait are you serious you know what I
wouldn't be in it now if they gave me a
million dollar are you serious I'm not
kidding you I was about to say something
else yes I was about say I'm not yeah
right if you ever change your mind I'm
never going to CH if you okay I get I
have things in Myer go you know what
themselves yeah
yeah that is brand new information for
me I'm just saying if you ever happen to
just also can I just say one other thing
okay I changed music forever with
believe you really did that song you
know it's so funny so let me say one
thing I feel like do you play a
Christmas song let me say one tag your
it okay no but I feel like that's what
like how massive and in pop culture and
everything and how it hit and impacted
the pop culture Community how it
believed it I feel like that's the same
Vibe as DJ play a Christmas song it's
that same Vibe it's no one has that
sound I almost think if somebody sent me
that song for my Christmas record I was
like I don't know if I could pull this
off I don't know if this is me like it's
so you the sound is so share it's so
incredible I love it so much I kind of
feel like it's the same thing like the
same impact the same impact that that's
anyway I could talk about you forever
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home